Political will to pay 44 billion euros to the European
Union 23 billion euros to manage a refugee crisis.
Oh yes can they let me finish?
Thanks for several three-digit billion amounts to save the climate that
somehow does not work so properly a billion euros to fight against the
right uh 400 million euros every year for child benefits.
The political will is there to transfer European foreign countries.
The political will is not there to ensure prosperity races here.
And we will reverse the principle as an alternative for Germany.
We are determined to do so.
We will stop this payment and where they belong - the
people who generate prosperity in that country.
And they certainly also want to know in concrete terms how we imagine it.
As 1.
We should be honest and then the Minister of Finance should
also transfer back the versicherungsfremden benefits of 37
billion euros to the statutory pension insurance.
The pension insurance pays something that has never been contributed to.
And that is 37 billion euros per year,
first of all to reimburse and then to broaden the base of contributors.
So that means officials include not all.
We say sovereign tasks should continue to be
bound by official status but all others.
We want to be independent and include those who
do not have an adequate pension product.
And we want to involve politicians.
And here I come to those who have initiated this debate in the first place.
Politicians who have never worn 1 brick themselves say people
tell people to work until 68 and among them are craftsmen
who really ask themselves questions at 50.
And we just heard someone.
She is not a craftswoman,
she is a nurse who wonders at 50 how are they supposed to last at 65?
And politicians say that you have to work until 68,
although after 4 years in the Bundestag they themselves
have an entitlement to EuroPension,
which is an absolute impertinence,
and we will put a stop to it.